hello guys today we're going to be
talking all about orthographic
projection
i feel like this is a topic that's often
not covered very deeply in a lot of
tutorials so i wanted to spend some time
on it
and within our code here which is going
to be up on github i've made a little 2d
game
and it looks a little something like
like this very straightforward we have
our player over here
and we have just like a little level
with something to jump over and we have
an
end goal over here a and d are the move
keys space bars jump
so there's three different states of
this game there's either
you're playing which means you can move
around and jump and collide with stuff
and stuff like that and it's a little
buggy i just custom wrote this
colliding code real quick so there's
some weird things like you can
you know there's a lot of logic to write
so we'll go through it here in a second
but
so you can be playing if you fall off an
edge you lose and you get this
x for three seconds and that resets and
if you actually get to the goal without
falling
then you get a little green check mark
and you win then it resets again so
that's all it is pretty straightforward
it's just a sample of how you can get a
2d platformer going because of course in
your code if you're doing a real game a
real platformer
you probably use textures and stuff but
you could essentially get away
with using all of this i've got a little
gravity going there too
let's talk about this orthographic
projection and what you need to know
now where do i start actually i want to
do a few things
i want to add a new folder called uh 2d
game and just put all this code that is
specific to the game
in there because it's not really part of
the rest of
i guess what we what we would call the
engine so
now in our main we probably have to fix
a few things 2d
game there we go that should take care
of it okay that way we kind of have our
game code sorted out in this
its own folder all right where to start
oh there's so much i guess i'll just
dive right into it and keep going
starting from the main let's flip
through it i've added a few new things
some are relevant some are not so
relevant i've added like a
ortho near and far i've also added the
last viewport
with it's going to save so anytime we
hit the callback
and do a resize at the end it's going to
just remember those that way we don't
have to call
glfw functions to get the window
width and height anytime we need them we
just have them
available i'm not even sure if i'm
actually using that but i was planning
on it when i was
making that little 2d game then i kind
of abandoned that and just
hard coded it in let's see
a little prep here all right now this is
where it gets tricky because
when most places when you look up ortho
they they basically just tell you to use
like
a negative one to one on the screen
edges top and bottom like negative one
one negative one one or they tell you
you use like
zero and then your screen width and then
zero and then your screen height
i think i'm doing that right that's how
they usually tell you to do it but i
didn't really find much luck with that
and i was digging into some resources
about making
2d games one of them was like all in
javascript and about making web
2d games so basically what you actually
want to do when you
are using ortho if you want like your
coordinate system to match properly with
your screen size
and for things to appear where you
logically put them
and your objects to be sized
logically with your screen size like if
you have a 1080 wide screen
and you make an object that's i don't
know
540 it will actually be half the size of
your screen
so this is just a way to to do that
because if you're programming from like
the negative one to one
you have to translate everything you're
doing into that space
and it becomes really weird with ortho
in my opinion after a while
so i i kind of like this uh literal
screen size
method and that's what i'm completely
using to do this little game that i
showed you
so you want to store the aspect ratio
that's important which is just your
window width
divided by your window height and you do
need to turn that to a flow because by
default those are integers
so you're going to need that because you
we're going to need to get
these variables there's something called
a half height which apparently is also
in the world of computer
graphics called the ortho size and to
get the ortho size
you take your current window height and
divide it by two
and then to get what they're calling the
half
width you take half of that height
that you ended up with from the first
one and times it by the aspect ratio
all right so that's a little prep to
upload that i actually
i think we're using this like down here
so i could move that down a little bit
and it should be fine
so notably we also do have to
recalculate these anytime we resize the
window so in our callbacks
under our frame buffer size callback we
do
actually do this again we uh yeah here's
the same code again
so with our new width height so we do
have to recalculate this
on window size keep that in mind that's
in there
all right very good so let's continue so
we set up
a new 2d shader so this 2d shader
is using a few
new shaders we have
the projected 2d and we have it with
this projection view and model matrix
that way we can move it around we're not
actually using the view matrix it's just
staying in an identity matrix again
and the projection matrix is the one
we're setting to that ortho
and of course our model matrix is what
we're using to move our players around
and set things in the world so if we
need to
shift things around we use that model
matrix
and i just made a colored frag which is
just very basic it just takes a uniform
of color
that way we can change it on the fly as
you saw in the game there were different
colors
of objects so those can be
just changed in the fly with our game
logic so we could
literally change any of these or
whatever we wanted to do but i kind of
like these basic colors just for starter
all right so let's close that again um
yeah so those are the new shaders
that we're using for that they're right
there in that source
okay so we make the shader check some
things set up now here's where we set
the projection matrix with those
variables we
determined so we take the negative half
width
and the half width those are the two
sides and then we take the negative half
height which is like the bottom
and the half height which is the top and
let's just yeah our view matrix is just
a model matrix
and that's mostly it for the setup there
the game code gets a little trickier as
you can see i was playing around with
the negative one to one
uh like we could see that okay let's
look at it how it is first do a few
resizes
because if we resize this window as you
can see these stay in the exact same
spot relative there's still zero zero in
the center they're still offset the same
so we don't have it like scaling with
the window so with this type of setup
you do want a fixed uh window size
usually
and that's that's pretty common for uh
for older 2d games it's that fixed
window size
because the scaling can get really weird
um yeah not sure if i'm saying that
right
so it might you know if you're gonna uh
scale your window and want everything to
scale with it
you might want to do it a little
differently but if you want it to be
fixed so that it like
plays the same for everybody this would
be the way
as you can see that check mark stays in
the center but these
are staying the same far away and i'll
show you that here in a second
so the only other thing we do here is uh
well we set up
our game code and that's actually done
somewhere else
which is in this game code uh we'll go
through that here in a second
i just want to show you the loop real
quick before we jump out of here
uh i changed i stopped setting the clear
color of the background i just left it
black because it seemed easier to view
the game that way
rather than the blue we were using
before
all right so we're doing a lot of the
same stuff we get a process
okay everything is the same i'll only
talk about the new stuff so the stuff
with demo2d
is stuff that's running our game code
like we said we prepped up
this 2d shader which we might you know
in theory
if it was only for a game we'd probably
move all this to our like game stuff but
we're still kind of hacking around a bit
so it's just uh
in here so beginning of the loop we
check the player controls
that's so we can actually move and then
after getting the delta time
we do an update pull uh given it the
delta time so that we can calculate
physics and stuff
and then before we draw we of course
want to do a clear
and use our shader and then just render
so all the logic of all the movement is
done in update
and there's a little bit of logic done
in the render as well
all right so let's take a look at our
game code first let's go ahead and take
a look at our objects these are just the
world objects we have a location
a scale a color and a rotation it's kind
of a weird
order because i added rotation last and
i didn't want to mess up my initializer
so i just plopped it there in the end
but usually i
would prefer to have it something like
that but i just don't want to mess up my
initializer list
all right so and we're going to look at
the aabb collide this is just a very
straightforward collide code basically
we're looking at
rectangles or squares only so
we just do some very straightforward
logic here you can find code for this
online the code actually went off of was
wrong for me so i had to do some
adjusting
so i basically take object one and
object two right
well you'd want the left side which is
the location's right in the center and
then you have to
minus the scale to go to the left or
positive the scale to go to the right so
we're just checking the edges
and making sure the boxes are i don't
know how to do this with my hands but
we just want to make sure the boxes have
a diagram drawn but whatever we just
want to make
sure the boxes are inside each other
that's all this does if they're inside
each other we return
true otherwise would return false so we
can check this collides with any time we
want
just pass it to objects it will return
true if they collide false they don't
pretty straightforward but very common
code you could expand this to 3d
by adding another dimension and it'll
work just as well
now keep in mind that this doesn't take
into account rotation so if you're
rotating
your squares and you're going to have to
do something different and it might be
better to use something like sphere
colliders in that case
which are pretty straight forward too
but we're not going to talk about them
in this episode
all right now let's check out the game
code this will be the last part
this is a little messy i kind of just
left it as it was once it was finally
good enough so keep that in mind i went
ahead and threw in a namespace that way
it's really obvious
in our main uh when we're using this 2d
code
it seemed a little better that way i
could you know in theory we could also
make this a class and encapsulate it all
within a class or something like that
but ultimately it doesn't matter as long
as it gets the job done and it's clear
enough
that's fine so we are going to hold a
game state and this is just so we can
decide what to display and whether we
want to keep updating the controls and
things like that
you can either be playing you could have
either won or lost
and you already saw those states so we
start out with plane
and we also have a struct for our player
we could put this in a different header
but it is very specific to this game so
i left it in here
so our player holds a speed jump power
and object
which is just our body so of course our
player
needs its own little body and that's
just another one of these
so just a way we can expand it so we
want our body and then we have some
logic for all the movement stuff left
right
jump this is just if you're moving left
if you're moving right if you're jumping
and whether you're falling so later you
see that
we set those as we press our hotkeys all
right and here's some
ass assets these are just all the stuff
on the ground
uh these are the two leftmost squares
this is the one you gotta jump over
these are the two right side ones
you can't see two because they're lined
up perfectly
next to each other and since we are
using
objects of size let's see here
you know negative one to one our plane
is
all ones that does mean
that when we scale the second one here
is the scale
it's going to scale on both sides 100 so
it's actually 200 wide when you scale it
by a hundred because it scales times one
on each side if we were like 0.5 then it
would actually be the width of 100
because it will scale half that on each
side
hope that makes sense but that's
something i had to like dig into a
little bit
as i was lining these up so yeah these
are just all the floor
and the things we can jump on and i'm
just calling those just
objects really they're like the floor or
something it might be a better name
all right and then we instantiate our
player which just goes off the struct of
course
use an initializer list and that way you
can set your speed you can set your jump
power on the fly so you can
move these or change these as you get
power ups or whatever in your game if
you want
and stuff like that of course we have
our body which we just initialized
with a location a scale
so we're just making a little 15 by 15
box and this uh that bluish purplish
color
so that's our player initialized and
then we have a goal which is that little
which was that little green square on
the right and it's just uh
that quick object code uh there's this
placement there's its scales
and there's its color mostly green and
then we have a couple
last objects and uh one of them is
called the lost
display so if you lost the game this is
what displays now this is just
two squares that are slightly rotated as
you can see there's some rotations there
that make the red x as you can see
they're red so i could probably format
this code
a little better looks like the auto
format doesn't uh
straighten out this here but so whatever
i'll just leave it
all right so that's the x
and this is that green check mark as you
can see it's just uh it's got some
logical placements to be a green little
check mark
i had to like custom nudge it around to
look perfect but i think it looks pretty
good now
and then we do have a reset which just
resets our player
and sets the game state back to play
so as you noticed our game like reset
once we got to the end
and that's all that is all right so
as our game goes and it just goes
through this main loop here
we just go check player controls update
render
check player controls update render over
and over so we'll look at that in our
game code
we check player controls which is
somewhere way down here
here we go so on a press of a we say
left is true on releasing a we say left
is false
so we're going we are checking the
release to stop moving
you will just keep moving if you never
release it and
yeah we do that for the right as well
and we do it for jumps so that's all we
have is left right
jump that's all we need at the moment
for what we're doing now in theory you
could think like okay maybe i want to
swing a sword or shoot a gun or whatever
you could
check last direction moved for which way
you're facing and then
do it in that direction and stuff like
that all right so the jump
jump is where it gets really tricky for
the colliding stuff at least for me
because you have to take in account
the jump and like gravity falling so i
programmed that in here a little i
didn't make it super
elaborate uh i really just won it so
it's
it's kind of janky code but as you could
see it it generally works enough for
like a quick demo
so if you hit the space bar if you're
not currently jumping
it sets jumping to true now i probably
need like a little more logic like this
like and like layered
dot i don't know i i need to make sure
you're grounded
like you can't jump if you're not
grounded so there could be a tiny bit
more logic here
to check that you're actually on the
ground but instead
i just did something a little different
i said for the release
if you're currently jumping the jump
equals false and this is so you can do
small
jumps the longer you hold it the higher
you go it's one of those systems
and if the player is not falling when
you release it then the player
is now falling but that also is within
this jump so if you were jumping
and not falling and then you start
falling when you release it and that's
what gives it
the the customizable arc which i will
demonstrate again
uh so if i tap it real quick just a
little tiny jump if i hold it goes way
up
until i let go so quick little system
there
like i said this isn't perfect if you
may if you like want to play around
clone this and play around with it
you're welcome to make pull requests and
and i will uh give you a shout out if
there's anything cool that you add or
make anything better
because this is just a one-man operation
right now and you know how one-man
operations are
you always miss something it pays to
have a partner
and i don't really have a code partner
in crime right now
so it's all me um
let's see okay so yeah that's the
player controls so let's check out the
update because that's
basically where all the main logic
happens so with this update of course we
took in that delta time so we could work
with it
and the first thing we want to do is
update the the game state
so we want to know which one we're on we
have an end
display length now i could put this
somewhere else this is just how long it
shows that check marker x
and it's three so we have a little timer
here too just for uh
to keep track of how long it's been
going that way we can time it
and i'm i'm going to not talk too much
about timers going forward i think
because it's going to be a lot of
repeating there's a lot of timers
involved as you might guess
things have cool downs you don't want to
be able to spam them things like that
all right so we check the game state if
you're playing
we just break out a switch statement
because there's nothing to do we just
continue on with the logic below
however if we won or if we lost
then we start counting the timer and if
the timer exceeds the length
then we set the timer back to zero and
reset the game which is going to
call this function set it back to plane
and reset the player position
so there we go
but majority of the time we're going to
just break down to this bottom logic for
playing
and one of the first things we want to
do as we start this update
we're going to make a copy of the
player's body and the reason we're doing
this is
because in case we run into something we
want to go back to the previous position
otherwise we're going to end up inside
of objects
so we just want to keep track of where
it was before
we processed all the update basically
and now we have some quick
jump logic uh you can see here getting
the jump right
is really hard so i basically well we
have a jump timer
which is basically how long you have
been jumping for
and i've got it for a maximum time of
0.6
so if you're jumping and you're not
falling
then it starts taking up this jump timer
how long you've been jumping forward
and i set it i just hard coded it to 0.6
that seemed okay so the maximum length
of time you can jump for is
0.6 otherwise it's going to start making
you fall
which we'll see here right here falling
equals true and the jump timer is now
zero
so otherwise if you are still jumping it
just pluses your y location based on
your jump power and the delta time
not the perfect jump logic it's very
floaty a little weird but
it gets the general job done there okay
so if you're falling
we have some logic here too and we have
some timers
because we need to do gravity you know
you start falling faster and faster as
you go
i didn't cap the gravity because it
doesn't seem relevant in this small game
so basically we have a fall timer and we
have a last fall velocity
we're going to use this last fall
velocity a little later so don't worry
about it too much
but basically if the player is falling
um
well we're going to hold our gravity
constant which i'm using 4.1
it's kind of a weird place to declare it
but whatever it works
and we just once you're following we
start the fall timer and
we just minus the player y location by
the gravity times the fall timer so as
this fall timer
increases it's going to be a a bigger
multiplier on this gravity and you're
going to start falling faster that's the
whole point of that right there
and the reason we're keeping this last
fall velocity
is because we need to check the floor
like as you noticed you can actually
walk off the edges
without keeping track of like how
far are trying to think how to explain
this is kind of weird to explain
but basically when you're falling if
you're falling
really fast you'll bounce
back off the ground a little higher it's
it's weird it's it's
kind of awkward to get right so anyway
if you're not falling it just resets the
fall timer to zero because
you're not falling and that may
basically makes the gravity and speed of
your fall reset if we don't do this
every time you fall your fall
faster and faster would be it'd be weird
alright so let's check the quick
movement this is really simple
if the player is got their left or right
set we just move them in that direction
which is based on their player speed
times the delta time
pretty straightforward there and then we
check for new
collusions or collisions check for new
collisions
now this is a very the more complicated
of the code
i it looks pretty straightforward here
but let's go through it real quick so if
we only want to check for collisions if
the player is actually moving so if
player left or
right or jumping or falling so basically
if they're moving in some way
then we're going to start doing stuff so
first of all we created a boolean called
on something now this is like
the whether you're grounded or not check
so we're going to assume that you're not
on something at the start of every
collide check and if your players not
jumping and not falling
and you're moving left or right we want
to check if you're still on the ground
we want to check if you've walked off a
ledge
if you're moving left or right but
you're not jumping or falling so that's
what all of this is
so this is where that last fall velocity
comes
in again because i want to look at the
player's feet so i just declared a new
object called the player's fee
i'm going to copy the body to start and
then i'm going to say the feet location
is a little bit lower than our player
it's our last fall velocity
that way it does that way we don't
accidentally
chunk down a little bit like every one
of these like
every check otherwise you start like
just slightly chunking down it's really
weird so
you need to hold this velocity so you
check actually below your player just a
tiny bit
to see if there's something below it so
that's why we got this last fall
velocity
then all we do is we just go through all
the objects and see if they're colliding
and if we are colliding with something
we say we're
on something now this doesn't check the
left and right side
properly so you can like stick to walls
which is a little weird but i just left
it because i was like
it's going to take me a while to
program in all the sides of everything
you know i didn't i didn't want to go
that far
so basically we just see if we're
colliding with something i guess you
could assume that you're hanging on to
a ledge so even if you like land on a
ledge you can still
clamp onto it maybe you're a lizard or
something i'm not sure
or a spider so then at the very end we
say hey if you're not on something and
you're not jumping
then you're falling so we set falling to
true which uh
we work out a little later here then
after all that
check for new collusion this is this
here is actually we should probably have
more comments
we should do something like this should
probably be right here
check grounding there we go and this
once we get past all of that the main
thing we're going to do is be setting it
whether we're falling or not and this
whether we're on something or not which
we'll use a little bit later too
then we just want to do a general
colliding check
just go through all the objects check if
it collides with
the player on any of them
and if your players falling we want to
uh okay so
this is if true if true it goes into
this
so if you're falling and you collided
with something then it sets you back to
your previous player location that
location we saved
and then following is now false and your
jump timer is now
zero which means you can jump again
basically
and if you're moving left or right then
it sets you back to the previous
location so if you did collide
it just sets you back to your previous
location and resets variables as needed
and the last part of it this is just the
endgame conditions
it checks if you're colliding with the
goal if you're climbing with the goal
it's going to set game state to 1
and if you're colliding with or well if
your location's less than negative 400
that's like a kill zone so if you fell
off the ledge basically
it's going to set it to lost and we'll
see those here in a second under render
so under render we have a big switch for
the game state
if you're playing
then we're going to draw all the objects
which is all the floor
and the platform and we're going to draw
the player
and we're going to draw the little n
square so if you are currently playing
you
basically renders the whole world and it
does that by
you know setting the model matrixes
we're using translate and scale here
as you can see first it translates then
it takes that result and it scales it
and it sets the color to whatever the
color was and it does that for all of
them so we couldn't theory move these
around
and stuff but we're not going to do that
we're just leaving them stationary
and then you know after we update each
of them we we draw them with this stroll
strip still just using that trolling
strip so in another case
if you have won the game then it just
displays
uh those two little squares that look
like a check mark
so we have that and as you can see we
now rotate so we do the translate first
in this case
and then rotate second if you have a
rotate you need to do that second
and then scale you can find these
functions on gm on glm if you're not
familiar with them
translates pretty straight forward and
it's right there
and the rotate takes more stuff
basically needs to know
how much is the rotation and which axis
and then scales last of course so rotate
will return something and it's gonna
take that matrix and scale it so there
we go translate rotate scale
very good and it's the same thing with
lost except this is a
a red x so if you're in the game state
lost
it's a red x and based on that timer we
were looking at
earlier uh way at the top of the update
seem to have lost it here's a lot of
code all right
yeah so if you want or lost and it
starts that end display timer
and resets when it's done and there you
go that's all the code
that's a little 2d game using
orthographic projection
and that's showing you also how to do
the aspect ratio stuff
to keep it clean
and easy to reason about now there's
probably a lot more to ortho but i was
just trying to cover
stuff that's not covered in most
tutorials and this whole aspect ratio
and actually making a 2d little
platformer didn't seem to be covered
another big thing people use this for is
isometric games so
maybe we'll do a demo of something like
that here in the future
but for now just wanted to show you this
one and
hopefully you can use some of this code
in your game or helps you
please let me know if there's any other
cool tricks or cool resources for
orthographic projection
feel free to share those down below so
we can all take a look
i do now have a discord it's been up for
a little while but if you're
messing with code and stuff and want to
share or just have questions you can
jump in there and chat with some other
people who are interested in technology
and code and if you want to go the extra
mile and supporting this channel
i do post some stuff on patreon at least
a couple times a month and i'm very
quick to answer any questions any
patrons have and you also get a special
tier
in discord if you are a patron i just
want to say thank you all
special shout out to the patrons of this
channel for this month for helping
making videos like this possible they
really do make this possible
so without the patrons i would not
hardly make videos ever so
i just want to say that it really really
really does
actually mean a ton and really does help
me keep going all right
i'll see you guys in the next one thanks
for watching matt
go tech tutorials over and out keep
coding and i wish you all the best
[Music]
[Music]
you